hi there I'm John Oliver
and I'm here with Cookie Monster High
yeah it's very exciting for me cuz I'm a
big fan of this guy oh really well you
know what me big fan of you too well
that's very nice of you cookie mom yeah
you know what me never miss you show me
love it well that's amazing thank you
thank you thank you me do have some
ideas though you know maybe four stories
okay yeah sure yeah big story okay Jim
can give us huge you ready okay yeah
oatmeal cookies good breakfast food or
only sometimes food okay that's not
that's not quite the area that we're
looking okay okay with this one okay
sure okay why do sugar plums only dance
in the head not in me mouth see with me
me like that i Tori witting store I do
see what you may I'm not gonna sack that
core anticip okay you got another one go
for it
when will science find a way to turn
crumbs back into cookies just brilliant
ideas scientists stepped up the plate so
you're like a go okay let's make this
happen that's it well that's it that's
it that's a plea that's good it's
interesting stuff it's not quite we're
looking for wind mainly here to remind
people to watch our special report on
words oh yeah one words oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah brought to you by all the
letters of the alphabet right yeah and
viewers like you
also brought you our Sesame Street and
Mashable oh yeah yeah that's exciting
lately got one more okay go for it
why don't they just make a whole cookie
out of chocolate-chip see what me saying
you have me the only one who think about
this no you know you're the only one
that goes into it at this depth meeting
just could go deep into story okay okay
I'm my apache hitting hand on the table
that's will drive it home that drive it
home yes there is no point which is not
emphasized better with that thank you